foreign
I think we have our close to foam
contingent of subcommittee members
um present so I guess
um we can get started
um this is a subcommittee meeting on
retained Bill House Bill 437
dealing with literacy
um
and uh this subcommitting meetings are
more informal
um you know there might be some people
in the audience who wish to speak so we
can we can entertain that
um but uh first I'd like to
mention I've passed out uh and updated
um draft
of HB 437
um
it is still a work in progress we're
still tweaking it
um but we'll have the final Amendment
for our full committee
session in in November
um so I'd like to uh first
start with
um
why uh
went down the road with this legislation
and it really
centers on what has happened or hasn't
happened with reading across the country
for a few decades
and if we look at
um
nape scores really can't see this too
well and I'm sorry I didn't have copies
for everybody but in fourth grade
reading in New Hampshire
and
the nape achievement level and reading
in the fourth grade was 38 percent
in 2022 it was 37 percent
in the eighth grade
in 2009
it was actually in 2003 it was 40
percent
in 2022 it was 33 percent
so
um
we are not making progress
um and
um I can
try and get copies for everybody this
this is a a chart of proficiency scores
in many of our schools
comparing uh reading Proficiency in 2017
18 19 and 21.
um and I believe the current state
average is something like 48.5
proficiency
um
so that I think demonstrates the need
and the fact that really the Department
of Education has been working very hard
for several years
in trying to change the focus
of our literacy instruction in the state
over the past decade
there's something like 26 states that
have passed legislation revamping the
um
and I have worked with uh some of
um people from those States most notably
a lady who was in charge of the um
legislation in Mississippi where they
have seen the most dramatic changes in
proficiency rates in their schools
um
so
um one of the things that department has
been
um
doing is training in something called
letters and I know
representative you've been involved in
that
um but I was at a letters
meeting on Friday
and updated numbers were mentioned that
over 3 000 people in New Hampshire have
now been trained
um via the letters program which really
um evidence-based reading practices in
the science of reading
um and they said that New Hampshire uh
far is Superior in what we're doing in
this Regard in the letters training to
any other state in the country which I
thought was uh impressive
um
so I think what I'd like to do is
um go through
um the legislation and there's a few
copies out there
um if you want to follow along but I I
highlighted several areas that I thought
it was important to mention
um and you'll see on the first page
number one is a universal reading
screener for Local District use
we are still talking about screeners and
um which screener but
um I I believe that there will be
um
resources available for the state to
help in providing readers to the local
districts
um and one change
uh here that I think you'll see
underlying on your uh your page
um is that we're doing the screening in
K through three but three times a year
beginning middle and end of the year
um
and some of these changes you'll notice
uh this is for instance in italics
and someone we've been working closely
with
um is Dr Tolman from New Hampshire but
she is co-author of the letters program
so I think it's been um extremely
valuable input for us to improve the
legislation
and
um so it's three times a year and you'll
see some of the measurable skills
that should be concentrated on down
below that
also one of the other changes at the
bottom of the page is that we believe
the screener should be given within the
first 40 school days of the year
and
um then uh also
um anyone coming into the school for the
first time if they haven't been uh
they're not coming with any information
on their reading abilities should be
screened also within the first uh 40
days
yes
totally different bill
[Laughter]
yeah
so if you turn over to the second page
Roman 3 you'll see a number two
and this involves the development of an
individual reading plan for those
students who are not at an
age-appropriate Benchmark according to
the screening
and it details what should be included
in that plan
including goals and benchmarks
monitoring of progress
and I think one significant thing we did
in F
um was to say that um
any instructional or intervention
programs shall not use the three queuing
method which is the most prevalent
method
um currently
um really I think around the state and
in many states
who have not moved to the science of
reading
which
involves the student trying to learn to
read getting cues rather than really
using
evidence-based research to
sound out the word and figure out what
the word is use cues like a picture to
help them identify what the word is
um
so we don't want to
continue using that framework for
reading but also I think important in
the individual plan are strategies for
the student parent to use
and that's one of the things that we try
to incorporate into this I think that if
we're going to really have a broad
literacy Improvement program in the
state that
um everybody has to be involved
parents for sure but even
um
a little bit further on you'll see that
uh local districts should engage the
state stakeholders in the community as
to what is important and why we're doing
um all this
um
and it's not included in this but I have
talked with the state librarian about
future
expansion of a summer reading programs
and things like that possibly in the
um
so on to number three Roman four
if there is
a deficiency noted
in the age-appropriate benchmarks that
um
the parent is notified within 14 days
um and you'll see there
um some of the
um things that should be discussed with
um number four is Romans six
um and this is where we get into the
engagement of local stakeholders we also
specify that the department should hold
periodic workshops for educators and
parents uh as they are doing currently
with the the letters program
but also the department should come up
with
guidance to the departments on
evidence-based instructional materials
so that the Departments have a a
resource uh at least to begin with to
see what they want to use in their
schools
um number five uh each School District
show report annually
about the progress and you'll see
there's three or four things listed
there in terms of what has to be
reported in these annual reports by the
school district
um I I think that one of the problems
uh or issues that we've seen for years
with the
differentiated Aid that we had for third
grade reading there was just money that
went out to the district with no
accountability or no information about
um progress other than that one year end
of year report so here we want to keep
an eye on what
what is going on and how the each school
district is moving forward with the
um
the department uh
I think is also responsible for a report
and
I think this is very important
um
we talk about
the teacher preparation programs
and
we want we we can't do a whole lot as a
state legislature to direct what the
colleges are doing
but we can ask them to report on what
they were doing
um a couple of years ago
um this group called The National
Council on teacher quality and ctq and
they issued a major report
on
uh the app the movement toward the
science of reading and evidence-based
reading instruction
and it was interesting they rated
each of the schools who returned the
surveys
and in New Hampshire there were four
and I'll read you the name of the school
and the grade for 2023 that they were
assigned based on their survey
Keen State got to be
Plymouth State got a D
Southern New Hampshire University got an
F
and the University of New Hampshire got
a D
so
if the teacher preparation programs are
not providing the necessary information
to teachers coming out of those colleges
were behind the eight ball and the
students are behind the eight ball to
begin with
so what I did
here you'll see in in G
Roman 11.
survey criteria that were used by the uh
the National Council
and
we're going to ask the department to get
the same information
that they did from these colleges
looking at the components
including phonics and vocabulary and
comprehension but for each one of those
lists the hours the measures
how much opportunity there is to
practice this and the materials used by
those colleges the same criteria that
National Council of teacher quality used
so I think that this is a a major
component that we've worked on over the
um
going down to the next area reading
Improvement Grants
this is going to change a little bit
because
we missed out on passing something last
year when we had the budget available to
us
to put in an appropriation
we are going to change this reading
Improvement Grant section to more like a
competitive Grant situation and we'll be
working with the Department to uh to
work that out and then hopefully start
these reading Improvement Grants in two
years with the next budget with an
appropriation there
and as you'll see in this there's
um different Grant amounts
based on
uh the grade level thinking that it's
going to be less expensive if we catch
student deficiencies earlier
and it's going to be more expensive
later so if we're not aware of it until
the third grade we have the highest
Grant amount award at that level
um
but in order to receive these grants the
district has to provide a plan on how
the funds are going to be used to
improve reading
an accountability measure that I think
the next next page
um
is section is statutes that relate to
literacy skills in the elementary
schools
and
um
some of the things in here that we've
done
is
to make sure that we're moving toward
evidence-based
reflective of science reading research
and the major components within that
that you'll see listed
um
and also repeating that we are not going
to be using the three queuing of the
balanced literacy
um uh type of instruction
um that has been used for so long and I
think it's in that regard it's
interesting to note
that that
method of instruction was made Popular
by a scholar by the name of Lucy Calkins
who has
um
recently backtracked from what she has
been advocating for decades and also
interesting to note that the
um
Columbia University
has
dissolved the program within the college
that was from used to promote this kind
of instruction
recognition of
where we have been that's not working
and where we need to go that has proven
results
um I think is widely
um uh accepted and one thing I also
wanted to point out was in relation to
the science of reading and I can make
copies of this
um there are all sorts of
um
lectures on UT YouTube about what's
involved in quote the science of reading
but at one seminar that a couple of us
went to
um they talked about the reading brain
and I've seen pictures of of kids being
hooked up
um you know with sensors all around
their head and their brain to measure
what is going on in the brain as they
are trying to read
um so that is what this the reading
brain is and it talks about the
different lobes of the brain and what
happens in each as they're trying to
read
um so I'll make copies of this for
everybody but
this and the research that has been done
this is what we're talking about with
evidence-based science of reading
research and I think that's important
to note as well
and the last section
that I wanted to touch on was we
last year passed a house bill 377
um
and that was signed into law
this legislation
um
encompasses
the dyslexia screening and instruction
as well as general reading literacy and
it in doing so it does several important
things in my mind
one is the move to three screenings a
year instead of just two
and it also
lessens the number of days
required for screening to begin
at the beginning of the year
um so I think that
we are taking another step forward
in trying to ascertain
um where and when these children are
having a problems in learning to read
and addressing them early on
um
and I do have copies
actually
um
for this is
this is
um a page on the reading brain that I
took from several sources
and I I'll get these out to the um
audience but also this is
this is the executive summary from the
report I mentioned by the national uh
Council on teacher quality
talking about
what they found and going into
um
more detail for instance I just opened
this page
um two out of three teacher preparation
programs fail to adequately address
phenomic awareness and it goes on like
that throughout each of the sections
that they believe are important for um
foreign
members for any questions and then ask
for if there's anyone in the audience uh
that would like to comment or ask a
question
any
representative I'll kind of kick it off
so um is this going strictly to
uh phonetics uh phonics yeah phonics
instead of uh at the exclusion I the
thing that bothers me a little bit is
that in several places you're excluding
one particular uh technique that's been
used even though it may not be the most
effective technique it's been used for a
long time and
um
I know just from my stent teaching that
when new ideas came along like this and
you had
um a big change it you know we went from
Whole language to
um
it just
stream of thought as far as language
arts were concerned and it kind of
there's a third of the kids that learn
One Way third of the kids that learn
another way and a third of the kids
learn another way and if you exclude one
of those you miss out on some of the
students and I'm just wondering if
um we have to put
that it's excluded
go ahead
I've been doing a bunch of reading in
preparation for this and what I have
read is that queuing's theory is
actually harmful even if used in
conjunction with these other methods
that it it it it
messes up I guess the way a child learns
reading and that it shouldn't even be
used in conjunction
okay I
I think that
um
yeah children do learn differently as we
we all know but I I think that the
basics of what they found in all the
research are these five six seven
components and even
um some people
um at a seminar several of us were at
um they talk about
one missing component and some of this
is knowledge
um and the increase in proficiency they
saw when there was six more months of
social studies
given to the students because they had a
greater knowledge base
to for the comprehension aspect which is
in here on the first page f is reading
comprehension so if you have a greater
knowledge base
comprehension will increase also
um so you know yes children learn
differently but I I think that from the
research these are the basics that the
experts have said should be present and
yes
well one of the things I found
persuasive what you just said a little
while ago about this three queuing is
that one of the leading proponents of it
I can't remember what name loose
right that so she you would think
is an expert and then she is kind of
going back and saying
it's not so that that that to me is sort
of persuasive as far as maybe this is
and the fact that Columbia Teachers
College
um is backtracking on years of
supporting this type of uh instruction
but one of the problems still is that
um we have book publishers
who are um you know trying to make a
profit also and they are still pushing
um this
method of reading and one of the biggest
Publishers of this is based here in New
Hampshire
um but I think with the movement that
we've seen as I said 26 States in a
decade moving in this new Direction I
think that the Publishers will will get
the message
um so I noticed since I had
representative Lance Amendment before me
first of all
um that he included um mathematics which
I understand why you probably just want
to do reading at this point
um but he also had that it it would
apply to Charter Public Schools public
schools and public academies and I'm
wondering if in this bill it will
um and I I
um you will see often in the science of
reading and this evidence-based approach
um reading and Mathematics
um but I I figured it was a uh enough of
a hill for me to climb just on the
just as an aside I think that we need to
approach mathematics in a similar
fashion yes and we did do a couple of
things last year in regard to that yes
so yeah definitely yeah our math
proficiency rates are uh no better well
and we haven't really recognized that
there's you know a similar case to
dyslexia only with mathematics with
just
um you have to press the silver button
so the red light goes on
um and give us your name and position
good morning my name is Brenda Peters I
am the immediate past president of the
Northern New England International
dyslexia Association we have been around
for 18 years serving New Hampshire we
used to be called New Hampshire Ida but
because we represent Maine and Vermont
we were able to change our name about a
year ago so that we have better
representation in all of our states I
have been involved in this field for
almost I don't know 25 years since my
son who is profoundly dyslexic
um and we started this journey before
that I was in organizational development
and like moving along happily and didn't
even know that special education existed
until my son struggled so that started
me on this journey I'm now a reading
specialist and learning disability
specialist and a specialist in the
assessment of intellectual functioning
so I actually test children for dyslexia
and it was also on the director the
children's to sexiest Center and
affiliated with them for 18 years
teaching structured literacy structured
literacy is the approach that we talk
about when we think about the science of
reading and structured literacy includes
not just phonics and phonemic awareness
it also includes vocabulary building
knowledge and it is truly based on
science it's been around for 95 years
based on the work of Orton Gillingham
and then it's evolved from there and
what we know about reading and the
acquisition of reading is that all
children in fact the brain processes
information the same and we all learn in
this we all learn to read the same way
and that is by understanding and making
that parent association between the
sound system of language and the written
system of language and children who
struggle have difficulty with this sound
system of language that becomes apparent
when they're very young even third
fourth I'm sorry three four
five-year-olds uh we can effectively
identify these struggling readers which
is why we have bills like this in so
many places children do not learn by the
three queuing system which involves
visual semantic and syntactic
information using those first before
going to decoding the word and getting
the word off the page now the thing that
what people are attracted to about three
queuing is that and balanced literacy is
that the belief was teach a rich
information and the child will learn to
read you know teach them like
interesting the knowledge build
knowledge and they will learn to read it
doesn't work we've been trying that for
decades in all of our states it doesn't
work and when we have 65 of our children
not reading at a proficient level but
only 15 percent of the children are
actually dyslexic we have a tier one
instructional problem and the answer is
structured literacy which addresses all
of those needs so that's my two cents
but thank you I think this bill is
really important
um I think it's a great beginning but I
do think that we need to do all we can
to make sure that our teachers who are
spending over a hundred thousand dollars
to become teachers walk out of unh and
can teach any child including those who
struggle to read if they can't then why
what does this you know edu this degree
mean the one of the main purposes of our
children going to public school is to
learn to read and if the teacher can't
leave that with the ability to teach all
children then I think we have a problem
and in in Mississippi they require the
professors to take letters and to learn
about our language and you would think
well of course people are there learning
this in college they're not they're not
so yeah we need to back up the bus and
we also need to look at our state and
federally funded colleges and what are
we doing there to get that information
out
thank you many yes questions from
subcommittee
thank you
good morning and thank you for taking on
this important subject with the children
um I'm representative ball I am a
reading specialist although it's now
Labs because I became the state but I
was certified as a reading specialist in
New Hampshire as well as a special
education teacher
um just to touch on a few things you
were talking about the colleges and I
will tell you that when I became a
reading specialist I had no idea that
was a general education certificate and
many of us sitting at the table were
like well when are we going to learn our
specialized instruction on how to teach
reading we never were taught it is up to
the teacher to take it upon herself or
himself to um then go ahead and get
certified in a specialized instruction
most schools don't even offer it
um that was
just to kind of touch on that I'm also
concerned
um
literacy is including math
and so it concerns me that I do believe
we need to have a firm definition in New
Hampshire of what exactly literacy is
and it does include math and it's easy
to to Define that by just looking at how
we identify students for special
education in specific learning
disabilities because that is literacy
and it does include math and it also
includes spelling so my concern here is
that it often mentions when I look it
says a lot of decoding fluency but
there's nothing about encoding and
oftentimes what I have learned and I
also have been fighting this battle for
30 years to try and get phonics back
into the classroom is that oftentimes
children can easily memorize our
children with dyslexia tend to be
average to above average IQ they teach
themselves they compensate and so they
can easily memorize these words however
when you ask them to spell them that's
where you can find that they don't know
the rules they don't understand how the
sounds work and speaking of sounds
dyslexia is an auditory disability so it
often goes and it goes from generation
to generation so they must be taught
these sounds it is
has to be broken down and taught to them
looking at the bill the one thing that I
another thing that I notice is often it
says age appropriate and I personally
would like to see that as grade
appropriate because sometimes parents
will choose to hold a child back
oftentimes it is boys who tend to act a
little bit less mature so we really
should be looking at where should they
be in this grade not in their age
just something that I I would change I
know that um
representative cordelli was very nice he
we and I we spoke last year about this
bill and I did mention the part about
making meaningful gains to lessen the
different
um that section there that is language
that's from special education law and I
really thought it should be included in
this because we're not just looking for
Progress we do need to look for
Meaningful gains we need to see that the
Gap is lessening my feedback for that is
we need to put a time frame
response to intervention is not supposed
to go on forever it is supposed to be a
quick let's see if we can get if we can
close the gap it should go 8 to 12 weeks
after that the child should be referred
to special education and they should
rule out a disability there should be an
idea that there could be a problem if
they um you know there could be a
disability if the child is not uh
picking up
on the interventions
the other
thing I would like to mention is there's
also oftentimes we have to wait for the
child there's physiological changes that
happen in the brain and so the idea that
children are going to read at six is
really not going to happen for all
children some children it may be eight
years old they could still be reversing
letters and numbers they're still not
just putting it together and then once
it clicks when their brain is ready to
accept it they will so I think we do
need to make sure we're not putting so
much pressure on a child when they
really are they just can't do it yet but
we need to be aware of that and provide
accommodations while we are waiting for
their brain to develop to the point that
they can accept what we're teaching them
let's see
um
sure I believe that's just my feedback
I'm just I'm sorry because I just see no
no so yeah like all over the place um I
just wanted to mention um in terms of
um time frames for special ed referral
we've
danced around that issue
um with a number of of people
um as to
um should there be uh you know eight to
twelve weeks or you know what should the
time frame be or if we're specifying a
shorter time frame
um are we
pushing the child into a special ed
categorization
um so that's something that we've danced
around with and I think I think maybe
that dance will continue uh until
November I will say that that is one of
my biggest concerns and has always been
a concern of mine for the last 15 years
since I've been certified as a teacher
or as a specialty reading specialist
that is a huge
Pitfall in the special education law it
specifically says that the school
districts can use an exhaust all
interventions that they can try and
throw at the student
it could go on for two years meanwhile
that child is behind for two years there
needs to be a a way of shortening that
up in 2011 the commissioner of the
United States Department of Education
sent out a letter and I can get you a
copy of it but it's the in that letter
she specifically said that referral
suspensional education cannot be
deferred or delayed because a child is
going to be in response to intervention
RTI that if there if there's a if you
suspect a disability you are to refer
that child to special education now that
happens but the problem is you go to
your referral meetings and the school
says well we want to try X Y and Z well
at some point x y and z has to end
because if it doesn't we're just
prolonging and keeping that child in a
classroom where they can't access the
curriculum and oftentimes it could be a
child now in second grade and they're
still waiting to get referred to for
special education I've seen that happen
multiple times even within my own family
so I do think we need to tighten up that
federal law as a state we can we can
tighten it up as a state and say well
the federal law might say that but in
New Hampshire we hold our schools to a
higher standard we want our children we
want to rule out uh learning
disabilities as soon as possible or get
them into a more intensive reading
program
thank you very much
um any questions from anyone
representative Tanner is is there
anything
um in this I know you talk about
bringing in stakeholders and parents and
um but a lot of reading instruction goes
on in the home
um early and a lot of parents are not
really
not a lot but a number of parents are
not
readers proficient readers themselves
and and maybe just don't have the time
to spend with the child or for whatever
reason but some of it is that they just
don't know and
um it seems to me one of the
the things we could do in this bill is
at least put in something about
um and I know we're out of the money
issue but that Local Schools should
offer
instruction for parents uh you know not
not required instruction for parents but
the offer of having forums or seminars
at schools
um that parents could take for you know
the state would cover it
um yes thank you uh
um I did try and address that uh to a
degree in terms of the individual plan
that's developed for the student
um would include strategies
um that would be given to the parent but
also I did say that the department
should offer periodic workshops for
educators and parents
um so I think you're absolutely correct
in terms of
um the uh the information and the
instruction capabilities being provided
to parents and that's why I'm looking
forward to you know in the future
working with the state librarian and uh
advancing on what and how the libraries
comment on that
on that letters program was actually
open to parents as well to take I also
took the letters training and it is a
very basic training it's not a
certification
the problem or the challenge with that
is as long as we have fontus and Pennell
in our school districts in our state
letters is of no use because fontus and
panel is a scripted program and the
teachers are expected to be on the same
place on the same day every across so if
you have three first grades classrooms
in your District all three are expected
to be on the same page every single day
and you stick to the script you're not
to deviate so even with all the letters
training the teacher's hands are tied
thank you very much yes
yes
um yeah I I tried to
take a step toward
um
requiring the move to the evidence-based
research uh types of instruction
um
I went as far as I could in that regard
I'm sure that the department will be
offering further guidance in the
department and Technical advisories Etc
yeah the questions I'm sitting here uh
listening to this it would never be any
value
in inviting uh representatives of the
teacher education institutions for this
subcommittee uh to hear their side or
their approach uh or lack thereof and
teaching of reading based upon the
information that's been shared this
morning
I believe you know we could do that
um I I have uh talked to
um uh Mr Appleby from the Department
about
teacher preparation and so forth so uh I
could possibly ask him to contact some
yes
yes do you have
thank you
um thank you to the speakers definitely
to have the knowledge base
um
when I've only been out of the field for
two years but after teaching reading and
and overseeing special ed referrals and
whatnot
I too have a strong opinion about how
reading should be taught and no two
children
you know can use the same method but yet
we seem to buy programs that are
scripted
and they just don't meet the needs of
all the kids
um I'm a firm believer in the Jim
Collins good to Great Schools no matter
what that those reading scores are we
should always be an improvement mode I
don't care if it's 60 40 whatever it is
um so I'm coming from that Realm
one of the things about this this bill
is it has a lot of strengths and I'm
very happy to see that you've moved
language to evidence evidence-based
reading
as far as I consider a three queuing
system shouldn't even be a language
that's on paper
um I don't know if it works or it
doesn't but it's
if you've been in education like some of
these people the pendulum swings from
one extreme to the other
and it never just goes in the middle but
if you can make your school district so
that people have the skills and know how
to draw from the toolbox to be able to
address each of the children's needs
then that's what we need to give
teachers and schools but you need to
have a hierarchy that's going to go
after that and not just the current
book on the market really
um so I come from a lot of experience it
did look a little bit more from teacher
prep so it's been you know I don't want
to say how many years since I've been
out of college
but as an elementary major
secondary secondary and Elementary major
I did have to take foundations of
reading to learn the different programs
for different types of Learners and I
did have to take a course in diagnostic
screening intervention
now I didn't I don't know if they still
provide that but I would say
because of what we know in Reading those
programs should be much more robust
um I know that they they have to take
the Praxis one whether they're UNH are
plummet those are the two schools I just
randomly picked out
um they have to take at an elementary
major they have to also take a
foundations of reading test to move on
and get certified and the Praxis too
so something in that ROM should be more
robust and based on
evidence-based reading strategies I'm a
big proponent of that uh having worked
and reading over many years
I'm glad to see the Bible that I've
adjusted Dr John's Savage worked out at
Boston University was from Massachusetts
wrote a book under understanding reading
problems did a lot of training with a
um the other piece that is not new to
the market is I think the reading
specialist mentioned was the response to
intervention model
so it was a three-tier model and I think
what has gone by the wayside
is the fact that schools are really not
engaging in data teams and that's where
you
don't have somebody going on two years
in an intervention and then you say oh
maybe now I need a referral no it's
really prescriptive and all right you
provide an intervention for six weeks
you measure the progress you provide an
intervention you measure the progress
um and from what I understand I'm one of
my districts they no longer do data
teams which really made the difference
in Reading progress or not
but definitely still the responsive to
intervention is the model
in terms of tertiary services
and we had a very strong Title One
reading program and they were always
current but Dottie fair was at the
department back then and they were
always current in what was the right
method and it wasn't always what was
being advertised and and districts get
sucked into that pretty easily because
they offer companies you know offer a
lot of freebies if you buy their program
but you have to keep an open mind and a
kin I come from a district that had no
money
uh so we didn't buy the program of the
Azure and we didn't go whole language
but neighboring districts would go a
whole language we didn't believe in it
because kids need phonics
um sure enough evidence-based reading
says they have to have phonics and they
have to have phonemic awareness and
those five components I would stick to
those
I'm concerned about your time limit
and your benchmarks I don't disagree
with them yes they need to be middle and
beginning middle and end for every
student to make sure they're on that
trajectory but again in between middle
beginning middle and end in between time
those kids who are not making that
progress need to be picked up
um maybe the principal certification
programs need to have specialized
coursework in Reading because they
should know
you know not only just a special
educator but the administrator should
know all right why don't you uh based on
what we're seeing in this data team this
student might need Lindamood or this
student might need a Wilson
depending on how that goes so it leaves
and I think that if we could focus on
the evidence-based reading strategies we
don't want to take away local control
and I and I'm placing a lot of value now
on the department having a reading
specialist because somebody needs to
lead this charge
um
and and that's where it needs to be I
mean I'm glad to see Dibbles is out of
here though I trained in Dibbles and
used it many times but in the field now
they're using more prescriptive
um different types of
um assessments and I don't think we
should be talking about again a specific
program or a company name letters I did
training letters as well
um it's one tool in the toolbox it's not
the whole gamut but the evidence-based
strategies the five readings that's the
key
um I think once if if we can get
guidance at the state level in terms of
how to disseminate and make sure that
every District does that
the benchmarking will happen it has to
um I don't think you need the time limit
because that will override it because if
you're going to show Improvement you
better do it you know at certain
intervals
um I think
um
when there was a recommendation or there
was a reading specialist initially hired
and then it went to an English language
arts consultant
that person put together this wonderful
guide I don't remember the year of it
resource guide for dyslexia and other
related
um resources I don't remember the year
2016-17 and before that was the national
reading panel in 2005 okay and so I
don't like the term science of reading
simply because it's the term of the day
I would say the term of the doer what is
really key here is those five
evidence-based strategies whether you
call it science or reading or reading
first
it's what it is right so so that's a
good thing and I'm glad that that has
persisted
over almost 20 years because it's sound
um
so I think it needs some work I think we
should focus on the
evidence-based strategies
um
maybe throw in some data team
requirement
um
what were some of the other things I had
the department also has a website called
New Hampshire loves reading I think it's
called or something to that effect
you've probably seen it I would like to
see some YouTube videos on there for
parents and teachers
um quick little Snippets how do I help
my child they're struggling in
um you know phonemic awareness putting
sounds together well use a slinky
um you know I'm having trouble my kids
are having trouble with uh ending sounds
well here's some tools you could use I
mean you don't need to buy a book I mean
exposure to language helps children read
right
and the big thing that I I am concerned
about when you get talking about a
referral for special ed versus
waiting or providing intervention
is kids have to come to school in
kindergarten rating some basic words
already
or they used to come to first grade
reading basic words
but we have lots of kids from rural
communities that don't have that pre
learning
and those kids unless they've been
exposed to learning you can't sift
through whether it's a disability or not
and so that's why you got to have
somebody skilled and knowing you know
the difference between the achievement
the ability so that's a very fine line
nine times out of ten I'd go with a
parent if the parent wants a a referral
then let's start giving a cognitive test
that's all you need to start with and
then let's sift it out but you need to
rule it out for Peace of Mind of the
parent as well
um
yeah I I like no no commercial programs
I don't like any buzzwords like science
or reading
um
trying to think what else and the
reading specialist at the department of
Ed I think I'm hoping we've got some
foundations already in place I think it
needs to go to the next level of
requiring the data team parts
um what bothers me about this bill in
particular as a rep I'm trying to
represent all my constituents this
doesn't represent all kids don't we want
all our kids to learn how to read
somehow that should be in there
I mean right do you have suggestions on
how to emphasize that and the you know
I'm well any thoughts you have you can
send to me I'm yep no I'm I'm open to uh
suggestions that's for sure
yeah no I mean
aren't all kids supposed to have the
ability to do the state assessment which
is has a reading component once a year
um
but you would want to know any student
to me it doesn't matter the level of
progress as long as there's progress in
terms of
kids that I don't have control over but
you need to know otherwise you're going
to be losing a population and it's not
right
um if I could just touch on a couple of
things you mentioned yeah in terms of
the data and data teams um the uh
professional development
um session I went to was down in
Londonderry and they had an assistant
superintendent who was the presenter
talking about
um
data driven and the way they do it in
their District it was um
to a very very fine detail
um the spreadsheets that the teachers
had to keep
were extensive and you know I heard some
you know feedback that
um you know the amount of time that it
would take a teacher to input me all
that information that they wanted into
the spreadsheet so that's you know a a
balancing point I guess but I have
looked at some
um
systems of assessment that do build a
lot of that data for the teacher based
on the assessment so I think that you
know that's something that that
department should take into account but
also on the instructional side
um
a number of states have uh said
um to their districts you will use one
of these you know six or seven programs
of instruction
which I you know I wasn't going there
um so in talking with the Department we
said the the department will offer
guidance
on research base
instructional materials and we left it
at that
and obviously that makes to me it makes
more sense than as a legislator I
shouldn't be interfering in local
control and I shouldn't be interfering
in
the government mandate
I mean it's the right thing to do to
force this evidence-based reading
um
and that's pretty much it
yes representative work to be done okay
well it kind of relates to what
representative cascadin was saying about
addressing the needs of all all readers
or all students this is only pertaining
to those this whole bill really pertains
to those who exhibit a deficiency
so then I'm getting back to like this
one thing that seems to be emerging as a
a big negative is that three queuing
system of reading and not having it for
these deficient students and their you
know the attempt to address their needs
so does that so then
ultimately it seems like you want fewer
kids being deficient if you're teaching
if you continue to teach this three
queuing system that's inefficient are
you going to be
not addressing the needs of of readers
they will then become deficient does
that make any sense when I'm saying that
you if you continue to do uh the three
queuing which is inefficient with the
students not addressed by this bill
right in kindergarten first second third
that then you will have more deficient
readers that then the the
percentages that you were citing about
uh like nape scores for instance and how
low
how low proficiency is I mean ultimately
you want to address that and get that
so
I don't know if I'm getting my point
across but it's the idea of let me take
a stab at it yeah just brainstorming
here um yeah
um I think we we tried to go in that
direction by uh saying it had to be all
students screened in K through three
um uh and it was three times a year
um
last year when we were discussing this
there was some feedback that
um well if uh say in first grade the
student
um didn't show deficiencies then they
wouldn't have to be assessed anymore
but in people I talked to said
um you can mask that
um by the by using the queuing methods
and and Etc so that we wanted to keep
doing the assessments so that we would
catch those students and not
um have
um their
their Solutions Mask real deficiencies
in in Reading
um so you know we I took that approach
in here
um but any more
um ideas on how to make sure that this
is impacting all students some
like
the question was along those lines and I
was just wondering where
specifically you were seeing that
not all kids were being reached by this
so that we could make sure that they are
so where is the downfall I guess
that you're seeing
do you mean it's requieuing sister no no
oh okay no no you said not all kids
would be you said not all kids would be
reached right and and I guess I didn't
get that out of here so I'm wondering
where you're getting that so yes all
well some kids
um attend Learning Centers some kids
take online classes some some kids
um
have different types of learning
programs
um
I see so more non-public
we've got the bulk of the kids in public
schools but we do have a large number in
non-public different a variety I don't
know specifics but
um
and I just want to bring up the nape
scores there isn't anything in student
learning that did not go down during the
coveted years
so I would place a whole lot of value
not that they're not accurate they
probably are
but I wouldn't base all of it on what
kids daring did during Colwood because
if you've worked with that any kids
during that time you know they turned it
right off I don't care what age level
however I mean I think you had a 2003
data point of 40 at what grade 8 or
grade four I don't know it wasn't sure
but it was a few years after that that
the national reading panel came out with
their research and I'd be curious to see
if there was any increase after that if
you read about reading first at the
national level it was a total debacle
um because of corruption at the top
but us little peons down in the little
districts had some benefit of a lot of
dollars
um but again we're talking about
evidence-based reading and the state
also had a really strong when Title One
was more focused on reading and then it
slowly picked up math
and now it can fund behavioral
specialists or other types of services
when it was primarily reading based
the state had a granite state reading
Association
and then every region in the state had a
chapter
and those entities were very active in
the field to the point of having New
England reading Association
did a um
did Regional conferences and I presented
at those conferences and we've learned
from other districts around New England
and so that structure I don't think
exists anymore
so there was more of an emphasis
you know and it was more of a support
system around teaching reading now
there's been so many offshoots I mean we
have to deal with social emotional
Behavior I mean go figure right our job
is to teach reading teach math
and so something had to go
I'm not saying I'm just thinking about
it out loud now it's like obviously
um yeah I
I think the whole community
has to be be involved in this if we're
going to get to where we want to be
um so that's why I did
want the districts to engage with local
stakeholders
um and also
um
uh just initials discussions with the
state librarian about you know expanding
the work of libraries
um uh so uh you know that's I think an
ongoing discussion
yeah
represent Tanner I think on another
discussion has to be integrating
literacy into
um all the other courses
um particularly there's a strong
connection between music and physical
education and literacy and probably art
as well so
um you know when we start getting
programs and we start blocking out
things because we have to devote so much
energy to something else that
um it and I know a lot of places cut
back on physical education just went to
you know open Play time uh undirected
play time and literacy
um there is a very strong connection
there so in the same way with music and
art so I just want to make that pitch
thank you
hi there my name is Bibi Casey and I'm
from New London I wasn't planning to
speak today but I'm actually getting
text messages from somebody who's
watching it leave live stream and she
wanted me to share these comments and
her name is Christine Downing and uh she
was the curriculum director at the
Kearsarge District up until last year
and now she's currently a curriculum
director for I think it's Grantham
Plainfield and Enfield
and very knowledgeable on on this and I
commend her for the programming that she
created at kears Arch where very
detailed screening protocols uh lots and
lots of data I was a school board member
at the time so she would present to us
quite frequently so her comment here
that I'm I'll read to you is
um I would offer that have we done any
alignment to the state assessments to
key phonics elements the poor
performance on these assessments is a
Lynch in this discussion however State
assessments and reading don't typically
give us the kind of data we need to
properly inform this need and process
the state assessment should be a key
first step in supporting proper data
Gathering related to phonics instruction
currently we get scores only on Craft
and structure integration of knowledge
and ideas and key details about
informational and literary texts if
State results are the driver then start
with looking at State assessment design
which is the purview of RSA 193c and she
also has a comment about I'd like to
know how to Bill aligns to RSA 193e
which provides parameters in terms of
the role of the State versus local
control which I think you've been
talking a little bit about and she also
asks if it might be possible to hold a
Roundtable discussion to get some
information about what is happening and
not happening in schools I know
representative cordelli that you've been
having reaching out to a lot of folks
and having a lot of conversations and I
I I'm sure you all have been doing the
same
um but and finally I just want to thank
you for all of the work you've done on
this I've been around for a while
working on all of this legislation and
it really makes me feel so good that
these discussions are happening they
weren't happening seven to eight years
ago when we passed the first dyslexia
law I am you know have seen so much
improvement and I I thank you all for
your work on this I really do thank you
thank you for sharing those comments
it just made me think also whether
um the department has a title one
consultant
in terms of professional development I
don't know if there's somebody here
sorry is that working yes Kathy
McCaffrey the reading consultant for the
Department of Ed moved into that role
recently
and you had a question about potato one
we do have a title one
um in our department
no
body that you heard this morning I think
it's been a wonderful conversation thank
you for your thoughts and
um interested to see how it continues
thank you yes
being part of the state are you looking
at the state assessment
to see if there are changes that need to
be made based on Phonics Etc Nate you
are we looking at the state assessment
in regards to phonics
and these other things that we're trying
to make sure are being taught now are we
following that up
steps for reporting State assessment
normally
reported under this large subjects of
reading and writing Independence
so that's some analysis that is
thank you
okay thank you
all right thank you
um I think there's someone else with a
hello my name is Karen Laplante and um
first of all I want to thank you all for
all the work that you do
um I was fortunate enough to
um be at a professional development
opportunity where representative
cardelli was there and I learned about
his work on this bill
and
um I am a reading specialist I'm
actually a special education reading
specialist at a middle school right now
but I've worked this is my first year at
the middle school but prior to that I
was in elementary for 12 years both as a
special educator and
um as a special education reading
specialist I was fortunate enough when I
started my schooling towards the end of
my um
grab my bachelor's degree I connected
with Beth McClure who was essential in
putting together the last dyslexia bill
and I worked at her charter school and I
was trained in Norton Gillingham right
from the get-go so I've been working
with struggling readers for many many
years and they are near and dear to my
heart so this bill is very important to
me and very important to the students
that I serve and that we as teachers and
specialists
serve
so I thought I would just
um I had a little mix up on the date so
I don't have anything formally prepared
but I do want to just speak to the
components of the bill a little bit
um you know I see that there are a few
major components the universal screener
I know we've talked about a little bit I
just wanted to talk about the importance
of it
um I've worked in schools for many years
that don't have a universal screener and
it's very difficult for students who are
struggling whether they are struggling
and they're just under the cusp or they
are really struggling
um to be identified I don't mean special
education identification I mean just
looked at so that they don't slip
through the cracks the universal
screener helps ensure that kids are not
slipping through the cracks having it
done three times a year is essential
because when you do it at the beginning
of the year and the end of the year you
have no midpoint to guide you to say
this is working or this isn't we need to
tweak it we need to change it so I'm
very happy to see that the three times a
year is written into this bill
um also as far as the accountability
piece I found with the dyslexia law that
we had in the past although it was very
good and I was very thrilled to have it
it didn't really have that
accountability piece and I don't think
that the accountability piece should be
in there to
um you know be you know punitive to
schools I think that it's there because
schools need districts to recognize
what's going on at the district level
needs to recognize what's going on in
the school so that they can guide them
and help them right and then the state
needs to be able to recognize what's
going on in the district so that the
state can guide and help the district so
I think that accountability piece is
very important
and at the school level which I have
seen I've seen assessments being carried
out and you know laws that have put in
place be followed but we don't have that
accountability and peace in place
Administration and even teachers they
don't know what to do with the data
after that right you know they don't
necessarily know the steps that need to
be taken after that so I think by having
the accountability piece in there it's
very important the science of reading
based methods and materials
component that's in the bill right now
you know that speaks from
um I noticed that you know the screener
is k-3 which I think is very appropriate
the materials are K to five right so all
throughout Elementary School
and really in middle school as well
students
should
be taught with
um you know methods and materials that
aligned with the science of reading
um not just up until third grade so I'm
glad to see that that's in there up
until fifth grade one of the problems
that we have now in schools is that
there's a great disconnect between
um methods and materials that are used
at the tier one level which is
um you know your your whole classroom
instruction and what is used at a tier
two or a tier three level and ideally we
would have those methods and materials
aligned at each level
um students do all learn to read in the
same way but students who struggle need
more of those science of reading based
methods
um as you were speaking of those are
very important components they need more
time at the tier two level at the three
tier three level they need even more
time but they still need that
evidence-based explicit cumulative
systematic instruction
I'm not seeing that now I think a lot of
schools and certainly in my experience
specifically are still using Lucy
Calkins materials
so it's been out
um the information is there that these
are not effective
um it's been out for a few years now but
it's really just come to a head most
recently and schools I think are kind of
stuck
um and they they need that guidance from
the state
um to help them to know what they should
be using and help with funding so that
they can actually
um and I I would be thrilled to to see
that happening in schools
um it's very difficult for the
elementary schools to move away from
that Lucy Hawkins materials it's a giant
overhaul for schools and again they need
support in doing so
um I also have to say that the three
queuing system is something that I've
actually seen first hand first-hand
harming students
working at the tier 3 level for many
many years I have students that will
come into me and all they know how to do
is guess at words and it's so sad and it
takes so much time for me to turn that
around and break those bad habits that
they've been taught and the other sad
pieces I spend
um
so much time and energy and heart and
soul into providing good instruction for
these struggling readers and they leave
my room and they go back to class and
they're told to guess at the words so
for them to make progress it's very
difficult as it is because they have
whether they have a reading disability
or whether they have some other
disability or circumstance that's
causing them to be behind to have that
disconnect between their intervention
and their classroom instruction really
last piece well two of my things I
wanted to say as far as the meaningful
gains I agree with that that students
need to be making meaningful meaningful
gains I would like to see
um some time frame around that as far as
how long kids are in an intervention at
the tier two level before they get
referred for special education because I
too have seen students in tier two much
too long and we're not necessarily first
off using the right materials may not
have teachers who are highly trained to
be working with those students
but also
um
they need to be able to move on to
special ed or have the proper tweaks to
their instruction to
um help them improve and move along in
their reading last thing I wanted to
mention was the teacher prep programs
um I do have some personal experience
with that because my daughter is in a
teacher prep program at the moment at a
school here in New Hampshire and they
were teaching both
methods balance literacy and
um instruction lines with the science of
reading and they really wanted to stay
true to that middle ground
she knew better she's in the letters
training she has me her roommate she
just told me the story a couple of days
ago her roommate said to her
um
you know I think I'm gonna go she's a
Elementary Ed major as well and she said
you know what I think I'm going to go
with that balanced literacy approach the
science of reading approach there's so
much terminology and I just don't get
all that Digraph syllable types this
that and the other thing and my daughter
had to kind of stop her in her tracks
you know and say wait a minute all your
kids are not going to learn to read if
you go that route so that's kind of
where we are with with our teacher prep
um and I believe that's that's all I had
but I appreciate your time and um the
work that you've all put in
this Bill thank you very much for uh
coming in in your comments uh would you
take the question sure oh no not
necessarily a question okay just and
thank you I uh what what comes to mind
is I'd be curious to know if we can get
this data is how many schools how many
elementary schools use a universal
screener to start with
I mean I've I haven't had experience
with a district that has not and
obviously that's only three districts
but I can tell you that
um three queuing has not north of the
notch
um but nwea is a popular one
um Ames web is another one
I think some are moving towards acadians
um but I would be curious to see which
elementary schools don't use a universal
screener and if it's a lot
that's pretty concerning something fell
somewhere
pretty hard
I think the universal screener is where
we have to start you know that's that's
a very important starting point yeah and
like I say I haven't experienced a
district that didn't have one so
obviously it's an issue somewhere we can
try and follow up yep thank you
um
that's the assessment
subcommittee meeting and all the be in
contact shortly about trying to schedule
that
great
thank you very much so I I guess that
ends our our subcommittee and we'll get
Nigerian
questions
[Music]
education
history
mostly all he wanted to do to take a nap
did you like
me you know what because
I wanted to say yeah but like always
yeah
my son's a dart and they've been with
his parents weekend so he just wanted to
go
okay I'd like to go ahead with uh the
meeting we have scheduled for 11 o'clock
seeing it's a little bit after that at
this time uh the the meeting is SB 266
and as you recall
266 was a fairly lengthy bill
um dealt with a number of components of
statue from chapter 193 c e h and k
and it was like 22 pages in length and
we've met several times regarding that
um so here we are today dealing with 266
we have re I received from the
Department I'm glad uh Nate and Caitlin
are here
a request to make some changes to
certain areas of statutes that within uh
uh that I've just mentioned uh to
support the
um
Essa application process which we go
through does everybody have a copy of
the amendment that was on the table over
there there's extra copies right here
um
anybody that doesn't will pass them
Nate they're right they're all up here
so let me try to explain what went on
here in level lasts you know several
weeks prior to filing prior to the uh
11th deadline in September through the
15th I did receive two requests from the
Department from Dr Green uh Bureau
administrator uh for looking at the
accountability and assessment areas
within legislation
and there are two areas I took them both
down to legislative services to try to
get them put into legislation and their
response to me was you have a bill
that's exactly incorporating much of
this
already there in the name of SB 266 that
was put forth by the senator course by
Senator Ward and had a just a whole
boatload of areas within it that we
struggled with
so they said if you really want to do
something you're best just going back
and and
modifying what you've got in front of
you to reflect
the amending language which are reflect
what's been presented and so what I'd
like to do because we are going to be
looking at SB 266 I like to invite boy
Nate and and and Caitlyn up if you would
please and as we go through it there may
be questions regarding this
and
so we'll just in and and and look to you
for those responses rather than having
to call you back and forth back and
forth
do you both have a copy of this
okay great
okay
um
I've had some email discussions with
Nate since this and I think what we have
in front of you is what you know uh I
put forward to the uh um legislative
Services last week
so
um if we could
um
we can start going that this this
amending language deals with components
from 193 C and 193 H it doesn't have
anything to deal with the adequacy
formula in 193 e nor does it have
anything to do with uh 193 k
so with that
um on the first page we'll look at the
first page of the amendment right now
and you can go down and see the first
change here on this is when we're
dealing with program goals and
assessments for 193c colon 3
there's a change in line 21 scratching
out the word other and writing
open-ended performance tasks this area a
b c and d are a reaction to what you
have in line 16 the assessment
instrument shall include but not be
limited to
these components of the Statewide
assessment
Nate you've crossed out other and
Incorporated in there under 22 other
items types Etc could you explain maybe
a little bit why that that change is
necessary
yes thank you I know red makes me think
mute so
um there are a couple of uh items that
we've developed over the last three to
four years that are on the state
assessment that I would say don't really
fall into one of the first three
categories there and those are things
called item clusters we use them
primarily on our state Science
assessment and it's a way of more
authentically assessing students
understanding of Science by presenting a
scenario to a student where they
actually have to interact with the
scenario so that could include some type
of digital experiment where there are
two or three variables and the students
can actually look at the different
variables and change those and then
there's a set of four to sometimes seven
questions that all relate to what the
student is doing by interacting with
that simulation on the test we call
those item clusters and we wanted to put
in here other item types because that
wasn't an item type that existed when we
first wrote the statute we hadn't really
developed it and it didn't fit into one
of these categories
so this fourth category D just kind of
gives us the freedom to explore
different ways of assessing student
understanding on a test that may not fit
into one of the three buckets within
statute
thank you
are there any questions on that change I
think uh Dr Green really
explained that pretty thoroughly
okay let's go on down to lines 26 uh now
this is the language we have in law
where there's an assessment required
and as you recall from
Federal legislation we we are required
to test in grades three through eight
and one time in the high school
uh could you please explain what you've
done with this part right here on lines
26 down through going on to the next
page on the line four on the next page
sure so the original Statue talked about
how the state had to test once in an
elementary school grade and once in a
middle school grade so we had crossed
that piece out and added the language in
that we're testing in grades three
through eight just to make our current
statute consistent with our practice and
with Federal requirements right now I
think that language was just a holdover
from older statute that was prior to
Essa I guess is probably
pre-2015 or so and it just doesn't match
what we've been doing over the last uh
if we flip to the second page
it does note that in science
specifically science is only tested in
grades 5 8 and 11. so math and Ela are
the two subjects that are in each of the
grades three through eight and eleven
science is just three grades Statewide
thank you I I noticed that there's
one component within there which is
changed that the Local District had the
ability to do an assessment
in consultation with the Department
not having to gain their approval
um
how many districts were doing that
other than pace
uh and I would say so Pace was uh under
the approval of the Department of
Education it was authorized by the U.S
Department of Education we had to get a
uh what's called a 1241 waiver to allow
schools to do the PACE program
um and what we did on the second page in
lines five six and seven we've added
some language in there that still gives
the Authority for local districts to
pursue alternative means of assessment
by going through the department and the
U.S Department of Education the reason
we've added that in there is by by going
that process schools are still able to
access all of their Federal title funds
if a school were to choose an entirely
separate assessment without going
through either the New Hampshire
Department of Education or the U.S
Department of Education they would not
be able to continue to receive their
Federal title funds so they could do it
they could you know I think you and I
have talked about the Iowa Test of Basic
Skills as a possible assessment a school
could adopt that but if they don't do it
through the the steps authorized by the
US Department of Education they wouldn't
be able to continue to receive their
title funding so it's just a trade-off
there and we tried to specify that
within the statute so we still have a
means for providing schools to go
through that approval process and be
able to use an alternative assessment
and also still keep all their Federal
title funds
you'll see for for the committee the way
we had it before they could use the Iowa
or California achievement test another
norm-referenced achievement test
and consider that part of the Statewide
Assessment program but it conflicted
with their receiving federal dollars if
it was contrary to what the state is
using for all they can still do the Iowa
test or against Community test or
something else on top of what they do on
the Statewide assessment they want
correct oh absolutely yes yeah
sure yes
thank you for being here could you
define for us how many public academies
do we currently have in this week sure
yeah so there's only two public
academies one is Pinkerton Academy uh
which is actually where my kids go so
I'm very familiar with that particular
school and the other one is Cole Brown
and we also tuitioned to St Johnsbury
Academy
yes yes
thank you so on the online 22 on page
one no on line 27 on page one you
expressly said Charter Public Schools
public schools and public Academy and
yet in this one you're talking just a
school district
yes
okay so we just put in the language that
Charter School
um Academy public school right there
versus District yeah so I believe you're
talking about line five on page two
yes yeah I would I would say that should
mirror the language from the first page
yes
and again the reason for that is all
three of those categories of schools
receive title funds so they're required
federally to participate in the
okay
there's no other changes on that page
two other than changing some of the
Roman numerals
now I guess there's no changes there and
um
let me make sure we get that on page
three we're talking it once again we're
now 193 C 11.
uh where it says for the purposes of
public reporting the state shall use a
minimum in size of 11 to maintain
student data privacy was that 10 before
no so it's been 11 since the uh
authorization of Essa it may have even
been 11 during No Child Left Behind I'm
not sure but I do know since we first
adopted our state plan in 2016-17 it's
been 11.
a little more information on that we
have historically used 11 throughout
reporting but we had to Define it in our
Essa plan and that's why in essence it
kind of became the official policy of
the Department of Education and we
believe it should be reflected in state
law represent Damon you have your hand
up yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
for being here
so I'm fully respectful of the need for
student privacy I'm just looking for
some comment on how our small mostly
rural districts that never meet that n
of 11
how do we learn about test results and
that's a really good question that I
think we struggle with from a public
transparency perspective because if you
have a grade of students that only has
three students or four students in it in
a very small you know if we're talking
about you know a K-8 one-room
schoolhouse that has 30 students total
across those grades it's very difficult
to publicly report any kind of results
all of that assessment data is made
available to the school staff to the
school leaders so they have the raw data
they use it in their planning purposes
they use it to make changes to their
curriculum to training that they provide
teachers it's just where we publish
things publicly on the department
website that that data would
be either blurred or suppressed because
the in size is just too small
yes
so is it ever
aggregated across the grades and I
realize that's
murky but
like you might have more than 11
students in a cater for school but not
more than 11 per grade yes so we
aggregate it both at a school and a
district level so if you had
um you know 15 students even in a school
I mean this would be a very tiny school
but even if you had 15 students in the
entire School you could see the school's
performance publicly because that's more
than 11 and then in the district that
might include multiple schools and you
would see the district performance as
well and that small school would be
within that performance
further questions represent miler hi
thank you I should I I should note the
answer to my question but Define end
size for me please
sure so n size n refers to the total
number of students in a particular group
um and the group really depends on what
it is that you're looking at from a data
perspective so an end size could be the
number of students in third grade it
could be the number of students in the
school
um I think you know when we talk about
public reporting sometimes where it gets
tricky to report that out is student
subgroups so n size could refer to the
total number of English language
Learners in a school or the total number
of English language Learners in a Grade
sometimes the school might only have
three or four students that are English
language Learners and it becomes
difficult to report out on performance
when the N size for subgroups of
students are so small we see that
occasionally as well with special
education for grades where a small
school might only have a very small
handful of special education students
further questions on this point good
we'll move on down the page then uh to
lines six and seven where there's a
change here the department Shopify
testing entity as defined in the RSA
with individual pupil names and unique
people identifiers and other
demographics and statistical information
necessary to comply with state and
federal reporting
so we ran into I'd say two issues on one
particular piece here there's another uh
statute and I don't know it off the top
of my head but it's in the 180s that
allows the uh testing entities to
collect specifically student uh name and
date of birth we needed a couple more
demographic variables when we look at
some of our larger testing vendors to be
able to identify the correct students
and make sure that we're sending the
correct score reports to those students
and specifically I can talk about the
SAT so the SAT is administered in every
single state within the country so when
they're receiving test scores and test
results normally just within New
Hampshire a first last name and a date
of birth might be enough for us to just
identify a student but when they're
working with large amounts of data
across multiple States if they have more
demographic information they're able to
make sure that each student is matched
up with the correct score reports so our
intent with this change here is to make
sure that we can share
information specific to our students to
make sure that the school reports we
provide go to the correct student and to
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair can you just give us
an example of what specific demographic
data uh that would include so in this
case it's really just adding gender and
then in some cases for some of the data
analysis we do it would be looking at
further questions
okay let's move on down to the line 17
the testing entity shall destroy all
data on a schedule determined by the
state contract with the testing entity
so initially the state statute said
eight years and we were running into
some problems there because we're having
a difficult time identifying when the
eight years started and when it ended
and different students have different
circumstances so there are some students
that get to 18 they graduate high school
normally they move on there are some
students that may stay in school until
they're 20 or 21. in some cases students
that are special education students
continue to receive Services far beyond
that and so if you're destroying student
data at eight years that can result in
situations where a student came in in
third grade and now we're destroying
Student Records for students that are
still within that school so we want the
ability and I think we would welcome
input from this committee to develop a
more comprehensive schedule for how and
when student records and student data is
destroyed that allows us to keep records
in some cases but ensure that our
testing vendors are destroying records
according to that schedule
yes represent Tanner um I'm sorry to go
back to to the line six and seven the
demographic uh and statistical
information
um and you said gender and ethnicity yes
are the two and
um why those two unless the testing
agent see is using that as as uh uh
uh kind of a not not necessarily as a
pupil identifier but as an
identification of
um you know scores that that are within
certain ethnic groups maybe not doing as
well as other ethnic groups just seems
like uh if you wanted other people
identifiers it would be that they live
in New Hampshire that you'd have your
unique pupil identifier and then you'd
thank you
is can you can you explain why that
can't be as simple as that
so for our New Hampshire specific tests
it is and that's that's what we use we
don't really look Beyond just first and
last name and date of birth and we have
a New Hampshire identifier and that's
what we use there we do internally use
some of the uh ethnic and racial groups
to look at the test performance so that
as we see the test performing for
different groups of students internally
we may change different questions
depending on how students are performing
on it and so that's all internal data
that we use none of that is published
and none of that is used beyond the
testing vendor it's just for the
creation of the test
is that data sort of like the for ell in
like a city like a Manchester where you
have a huge population which is speaking
a different language or from a different
culture we get breakdowns on that
information yes
and our assessment vendor is the one
that provides us with those breakdowns
they have the statistical information
for the performance on each item so they
they don't provide it for specific
students we're not receiving that
student level data but we get on average
on the state how did each different
group perform on specific questions so
we can determine whether we fill the
questions themselves are were written
appropriately for New Hampshire students
representative
and so on that very Point uh so that
allows you to be able to disaggregate
the data
so we do some we can do some of our own
disaggregation of data when we look at
overall performance what we don't have
the ability within the department to do
is look at it on a question by question
basis so we just disaggregate when we
look at overall student performance so I
think to representative lad's point you
know we can do disaggregations and say
how English language Learners performed
on the test as a whole but we can't
necessarily go in and look at how did
English language Learners perform on
each of the individual questions across
the test and that's because we use an
Adaptive test and so each student sees a
slightly different version of the state
assessment and so it isn't as simple as
just looking at how did everybody do on
this one particular question there are
many different variations of each
question that are worded in different
ways sometimes the way a question might
be worded presents challenges to
students and we go in and we look at it
maybe there it's too wordy versus some
of the other questions that we use and
so that's the type of analysis we do to
determine whether we feel the question
itself appropriate and each year we
throw questions out we add new questions
in to make sure that the test continues
to assess appropriately
what our students know and can do
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I I might have been a
little bit confused I'm trying I want to
dig in a little bit on what you were
what you were saying as far as using um
ethnic data as far as creating the tests
and you're saying that they're adaptive
does that mean does that mean somehow
we're administering possibly different
tests to students based on ethnicity
no so it's it's entirely based upon
student ability so the way the Adaptive
engine works is a student will go in and
they might answer a set of questions
that's common across all students and
based off of how the students performed
on those particular questions if a
student you know aced every question
they moved to those questions very
quickly the test will provide a slightly
harder question to them next and then as
if the student continues to perform well
on those questions the questions become
increasingly harder and you're able to
determine the student's performance if a
student is answering questions
incorrectly it'll provide slightly
easier questions to that student and so
that allows us to dial in exactly where
students are at entirely based upon
ability and we don't look at any student
specific information when we look at
that it's just how they're answering
each question
yeah if I may just quick follow-up and
thank you for the explanation because
that helps but where where does the
ethnic component then come in because I
I thought you had said that somehow the
ethnic part is used in the creation of
the test is that is that right or no
it's usually after the fact so we have a
federal requirement where we have to
ensure that
the the way that students perform on
questions is relatively similar so if we
gave a test uh and I'll try to simplify
it a little bit but let's say there's 10
questions
um and we looked at how students
performed in different subgroups so how
your special ed population did how your
English language learner population did
how your free reduced lunch uh income
students did and we found that
specifically the free reduced lunch kids
um overwhelmingly got question eight
wrong but every other student group got
question eight correct we would go in
and look at that question and try to
determine is there something about that
question that's causing one group of
students overwhelmingly to get that
question wrong and that's the type of
analysis so we do that after the fact
it's once we have all the data in and
then if we feel the question is
appropriate and we look at it with
groups of teachers then it may stay on
the test but if we fail that particular
question isn't is unfair in some way to
that particular group and maybe the way
it's word did then that question would
be removed and we'd replace it with
another question but that would go on to
the next year's test and we have to do
that for all the questions for our test
as part of receiving federal funds so we
don't it's not public information that
we put out there it's it's something
that we do internally when we look at
how the test is performing and then we
provide evidence that we've done that
analysis to the feds to show that we're
represent Tanner thank you and thank you
for taking my question
um so over if if it adapts over years
um would girls get different questions
than boys
uh or would the test be leaning more
towards a male identified test than a
female identify test since gender is one
of the things that you're taking into
consideration as well as ethnicity no so
that that is one of the groups that we
would look at to see you know if we had
a question on there and overwhelmingly
let's say all the boys in the state got
this question right but all the girls
got that question wrong and we don't see
that on the test but if there was a
situation when that happened we would
look at the question and try to decide
is this question in some way written
that you know it makes sense to boys but
it didn't make sense to the girls and
that's kind of a simplified way of
looking at it but the the adaptivity of
the test is really just based off
student performance so the test itself
doesn't know who the students are so it
doesn't have anything to do with uh
gender or any student groups so I I then
I swing back in my mind then why do we
need to take those demographics I mean
if it just it doesn't make sense to me
that I I know why National tests do it
so that they can advertise and you know
Target their tests more but on a state
level I don't understand why we're doing
that unless it unless it's a federal
mandate which it didn't sound like it
was a federal mandate it sounds like
we're just putting that in
so in this case it's a federal
requirement as part of our peer review
when we submit our state test to the U.S
Department of Education they have to
approve what we're doing in our
Statewide assessment and part of that is
we have to provide them evidence that
we're doing that level of analysis so
okay let's move on down to the next
areas we're leaving the assessment as
identified in 193 C and going in 193 h
which is uh a little bit different here
it's uh now we're talking about giving
support to these schools which may need
that support so on lines Nate online
um 24 there is a change by Crossing out
the date and then I I know why you're
doing line 26 but why don't you go ahead
and explain it
sure so uh our plan occasionally goes
through revisions
um so we're trying to keep the date out
because we have
um the plan was updated in 2019 and then
it was updated again in 2020 with some
small changes we made as a result of the
pandemic and then we have a new revision
that was updated and approved in 2023.
so we're trying to keep the date itself
out of Statute just because the plan
itself every couple of years has minor
modifications and changes to it
um number 26 regardless of title and
status this is just bringing
um if you look at line 21 this whole
sort of paragraph section here is
referring to comprehensive support and
Improvement schools later on in this
statute it also talks about targeted
assistance schools and it uses the same
language regardless of Title 1 status we
think that that was an oversight of the
original statute
CSI schools are actually the more
serious of schools when we look at
schools that need additional assistance
so when we talk about targeted assistant
schools later on in the statute and we
add the piece about regardless of Title
One status
we do the same thing for CSI schools as
well so I again I think you know this is
just bringing it into
um compliance with what our current
practice is
um and it matches it with the TSI
schools if we don't want to include
non-title one schools I would recommend
you know not adding it here but also
removing it from the other section in
statute where it already belongs
statute yeah well we liked it where we
have some high schools which don't
receive any title Monies but need help
or are not you know doing as well as
they should as good as they should and
so regardless whether the receiving
Title One money or not they're not low
as five percent it's going to be
identified and they're going to get that
support
exactly yeah I would say this really
applies to high schools yeah because
they're just such a small number of high
schools that identify as Title One in
the state
yes representative cascadden uh just a
quick question I don't recall what what
does the term what does Title One use as
a terminology for their rating is it the
same CSI and TSI it is yeah all right I
couldn't remember thanks
going down to the next one now is uh
line 27 any high school with a
graduation rate less than U.S 69 percent
over two consecutive years now it's 67
period
so this is what's currently in our Essa
plan so we had two different lists of
schools we had schools that were under
67 percent under the federal CSI
definition and then our state CSI
definition here was 20 69 over two
consecutive years one of those lists
receives Federal funding and one of
those lists does not what we wanted to
do was make the list the same so that
when we identify schools as CSI all the
schools on that list receive federal
funding
and then I know that
um representative lab you and I had
chatted about this a real discussion on
this one I think it's it's really
important to understand that you know we
have a really high graduation rate in
New Hampshire our high schools tend to
do very well when compared nationally
we're in the low to mid 90s when we talk
about graduation rates as an average for
our state
but the way we Define graduation rate
it's important to understand is only
students receive a four-year high school
diploma so this calculation here this
percentage does not include students
that receive their GED it does not
include students that take the high set
and move on it does not include students
that are attending an adult education
program and receive an adult diploma and
it does not include completion
certificates as part of a special
education program so there are a lot of
students that are successfully ending
their high school program with a GED or
a hiset or adult diploma that don't
count in this percentage so when we say
we might have a high school that has a
65 graduation rate that just means 65
percent of their students received a
four-year high school diploma their
completion rate may be much much higher
when you add in things like hisat and
okay let me give you some figures that I
looked up and
I'm looking at four
high schools here
um
one north of Us Franklin which has a
graduation rate of 67.16 percent as of
2022 that Court
who has one student hiset
Manchester Central has 67.97 percent
graduation one hiset Manchester West has
58.56 percent
with five high sets in Pittsfield
has 53.85 percent with one high set
so we we have some schools that are are
fairly low here
and I know that when we've had this
discussion in other groups before we've
had Senators really go off the track
saying why are we having this this bar
so low why aren't we setting the
expectation that a level higher wherever
that may be whether 75 percent or or we
know that our average is over 90 percent
so if if we had these schools so low how
we can identify them through this
process to get that support they need
should we be identifying more schools
because there's a number of them in the
low you know the low 70 percent level
I think go ahead yeah we had looked at
the numbers for this past year and
looking at you know if we increase it to
70 or 75 if we increase it to 80 what if
you brought it all the way up to 90
um and the you know obviously as you
bring that graduation Target up higher
you end up with more schools on that
list
um what we want to try to do is find a
balance between the amount of funds that
we have and the number of schools that
are on the list because the funds are
split between those schools and so we
want to try to identify the schools that
need the most support when it comes to
graduation so we provide them the
targeted funds that they need to put
programs in place to try to raise those
graduation rates and I absolutely agree
we should have we should set High
targets I believe our state Target might
be like 91 or 92 percent that we've set
as our expectation is you should be
hitting this or higher the 67 of the 69
is the threshold for us to give you
money specific to you trying to raise
representative Tanner
thank you um so I'm wondering how
how you determine graduation rate is it
the number of students that enter High
School
uh that then complete
um their four years or is it just the
senior class how many people out of that
senior class do um and also
um I'm concerned that we've the
definition of high school so is that a
um charter school that offers uh grades
9 through 12 is public Academy again are
we uh putting all those groups in
together and
um I guess
those are my two main questions with
that how's that percentage you know does
it take into account that
you know 200 kids are in ninth grade and
only 67 percent of them graduate out of
that high school does it take into
account the kids that move out or that
go to another school district or you
know whatever they for one reason or
another don't
reach that 12th grade level
so in terms of high schools it does
include charter schools and public
academies as well okay um so across the
board If you're receiving any federal
monies through the title program you're
on that list we can certainly clarify
that here in this statute I think that
would be good okay
um
you do Post you do post the academies
and the charter schools on the web as
well right and just as a point of
clarification so high high school
elementary school middle school those
are great great groupings types of
schools would be a district Public
School a charter school a non-public
school whatever those are so there's
types of schools and schools great
school groupings so a high school no
matter if it's a non-public school or
Charter School whatever means a school
that has 9 through 12 in it kind of per
our definition so those are kind of a
type and a grouping are different okay
so thank you and then in terms of the
way it's calculated it's a cohort based
calculation so as soon as a student
enters ninth grade they're assigned a
year of graduation regardless of what
school they ultimately graduate from and
the can I not to make it sound high
stakes but the clock starts ticking
essentially once you're enrolled in
ninth grade you have four years to
graduate with a regular high school
diploma and so when we're looking at the
graduating class we're looking at every
student that entered ninth grade four
years ago and that's what we're using
for our calculation to determine whether
they're graduate or not so a student who
graduates with a regular high school
diploma but they do it five years from
when they entered High School does not
count in this percentage it actually
dings a high school and it drops their
percentage even though they're still
graduating and they're receiving a
regular high school diploma it's because
they did it in five years instead of
four years and that's why for some of
our larger high schools you see lower
percentages they have students that are
graduating but they're graduating in
their fifth year or they might be
graduating in their sixth year
wouldn't a school that had a high
transient population then be also skew
you know suffer from that as far as the
graduation percentage
it can I think the the schools that we
see that suffer the most from the way
it's defined tend to be the charter
schools that are serving
um student populations that are most at
risk for dropping out we have a couple
of charter schools that they are
receiving students who are already
entering their fifth year of high school
and so their graduation percentage will
always be incredibly low because by the
time they receive that student
that student will never count for them
they they can't count as a four-year
graduate because they're entering the
charter school in their fifth year and
then also we tend to see it skewing a
little bit towards smaller schools
because if you only have five kids in
your senior class and two of them don't
graduate in their fourth year
your percentage is based out of three
out of five students and that
significantly drops you and those two
students may still graduate they may
just graduate next year in their fifth
year but by then it doesn't count as
part of that percentage
do you ever ask Asterix those so that
they that when it's uh you know
publicized publicly that that that it it
points out those facts yeah so we try to
report this out in I would say about
four or five different ways and we talk
to schools about different ways of
messaging it to their Community as well
this definition of students graduating
in four years is a federal definition we
don't have an ability to control or
Define it and that's because it's tied
to federal funds so the schools that
fall below this 67 percent then receive
federal funds directly to support their
graduation rate
um but on the website we publish both a
four-year graduation rate and a
five-year graduation rate and then we
publish an average of a four and five
year graduation rate so that you know
parents and community members can go on
there and see okay these are the kids
that graduate in four years but here's a
percentage of kids that graduated within
five years and that five-year graduation
rate is always much higher than the
four-year because it captures those
students that you know maybe they
repeated their freshman year twice or
they repeated their junior year twice
but they're still on track to graduate
they just do it in five years and so
forth
represent Myler
tell us what the impact is of
so in this case the two consecutive
years is just part of the way it was
defined at the state level so that's not
used in the federal definition and so
right now the schools that have that
meet this definition of two consecutive
years don't receive any funds the
schools that meet the federal definition
right now of just a single year do
receive federal funds for their program
so that's why we talked about
eliminating it here because the having
the list that includes two consecutive
years is a list that gets published but
there's no money attached to it because
it's just within the state definition
so by dropping this from 69 to 67 of
those four high schools I talked about
you're eliminating two of them
from receiving because there's 67 point
something
they're over that 67 percent
so is this a wise decision should we
keep it at 69 where we currently are we
made that decision as a state
so we would allocate I assume
we're not allocating the title one money
we can't because the federal law says 67
so those those ones right there in that
grouping they'd be identified for State
purposes but there's no additional
assistance that we could provide them
so we can't use Title One monies where
there got that rate you know we can only
use Title front title funding for where
it aligns with the federal law and where
this would be out of we're currently
right now out of line with the federal
law I mean there's nothing prevent you
from coming up with a state program to
support these additional schools but
right now so all we would do would be
identify those schools we'd say well
there's two of you you get nothing
everybody else you get something because
you do meet this Federal criteria so
there's just kind of these two that'd be
stuck in no man's land we couldn't do
anything so we have in Item B here just
above this area we're talking about
those schools which don't receive Title
One support would be receiving they'd be
classified as a comprehensive support
Improvement School
so but we're not going to provide them
any support
so for the ones that are six that do not
receive Title One funding right now that
it would only be identified for State
purposes there's no additional supports
that we can provide them
so we're just going to identify them
that you're
we've we agree that that is a challenge
that we should work together as a
committee to to resolve but yes that's
right now there's so there are um and I
should say there's technical correction
and action plans that are required
um later on in RSA I think it's RSA 193
E5 or something like that
um that it's further down it talks about
um there's essentially four years of
potential corrective action plans that a
school must implement but there's no
additional supports that the Department
of Education is able to provide in the
form of funding and or contracted
assistance so for the title one schools
that are in the bottom five percent
schools that are CSI schools we have
contractors that we pay for our federal
funds that help schools go out and they
do a review they needs assessments for
the schools and they help the schools
put plans in place to implement that in
addition the schools also receive we
call it a 1003a grant from our Title One
office at the Department of Education
and they receive
um I think it's anywhere from like 25
thousand to several hundred thousand
dollars depending on the size of the
school to implement those um those items
identified in the needs assessment so
that's true right now there is no
additional
um additional State support for those
schools so help me out here Caitlyn so
that the title if you're considered a
a recipient as a district the district
doesn't have the option to spend those
dollars
where they want in which schools it's no
so there's two there's two parts of
title one uh so there's the Fig lard 40
million dollar Title One grant that most
districts across the state get and the
schools or the districts are required to
provide those funds to their media
students so for the most part schools
rank order there's their sorry districts
rank order their schools in order of
poverty and allocate the funding of the
schools so that's the big Title One
Grant there's a set aside the Department
of Education receives in title one which
is seven percent of our Title One Grant
and so what we do is we take that money
off their Title One off the top and we
set that aside for once the CSI
determination has be done has been done
so we at the department of education do
these rigorous calculations defined here
and law to determine what the CSI
schools will be and the those bottom
five percent of schools will receive one
the technical assistance and two a grant
of that so that set aside Grant but that
is is only right now for elementary
schools that are Title 1 status or any
school any high school that has a
yeah representative cascaden yes so they
would receive
substantially as a CSI score TSI school
if the graduation rate like you
mentioned yeah
not the ones that are 67.1 so in the
list that you mentioned I believe it was
right is below right yeah right below
67. so have you been
directing this money when we've had it
at 69 for two consecutive years have
they been receiving money no we can't we
can't do that
so and I think part of the confusion is
is
in 2017 we wrote this we kind of tried
to kill two birds with one stone which
we said all right there's Federal
accountability in their state
accountability and it's mostly aligned
but there's a few differences and this
is one of those few differences
and we might be at a point now where we
need to start talking about well what
does State accountability actually look
like and should it be different than
what federal accountability is because
if you remember the section of this law
as accountability for an adequate
education and so maybe we want to say
all right this is what you need to do
over here per your Consolidated state
plan for Essa and that's while the you
know 130 million dollars of federal Essa
money or whatever it is is contingent on
that and then the accountability for an
adequate education which is the state
adequate education funding of about a
billion dollars maybe we have a
different process for that but right now
they're kind of aligned and there's some
confusion there's a lot of people that
have been coming to the Department of
Education lately that said well should
we be looking at um completers so should
we be getting credit for those that are
getting the kids a GED or a high set
should there be some additional kind of
should that be concluded in your
calculation and we said those are
definitely good things to think about we
have our adult education program that's
doing a lot of this work and paying for
on behalf of the state but it's not not
included in the federal definition and
we don't have the ability to change the
federal definition that's in federal law
so approximately how much does West
receive in Title One monies I can look
it up
think would be a lot
but it'll take a minute so if you want
okay Nate why don't we uh scoot down to
the bottom part here and then come back
to this uh
when you're talking about the New
Hampshire Consolidated state plan
and I know the definition there comes
almost for fate verbatim from federal
law
yeah yeah I think this just helps to
provide some clarity as to what the SSD
um one subsequent change as well in here
is we removed every three years for that
identification period and set it based
upon a schedule set forth in the state
plan initially when the state plan was
written back in 2017 the plan was to
have that be on a schedule every three
years and that schedule was thrown into
whack with the pandemic we ended up with
sort of a one-year determination that
occurred in the middle of the pandemic
with a federal waiver and then an
additional one-year designation and then
back to a three years and so there was a
schedule that was every three years
based upon 2017 and that schedule kind
of went out the window so there is a
schedule that is set down it's approved
by the U.S Department of Education in
our state Essa plan and so we just
recommended here that we change it to be
the schedule that's in the state plan as
opposed to saying every three years the
goal is every three years and that's
what's written in the state plan but the
schedule's a little off as a result of
the pandemic thank you
to answer your question West received
and that's in addition to other Title
One money that Manchester would have
received
and we're looking at another school like
Central
67.9 percent
why can't the state kick in somebody to
help them as well there's there's
absolutely nothing that prevents the
state from doing that you would just
have to come up with a determination and
obligate money in the state budget
okay
further on that one
can you explain lines four through seven
see this is referencing back to the A
yes oh um so further down in this page
so on line 19 in current statute
it says any school that demonstrates and
meets criteria established as a targeted
support and Improvement school pursuant
to subparagraph a shall be identified as
a school in need of corrective and
technical assistance and subject rsa183
e3e so this
which is currently in statute said that
if you're a TSI school you're subject to
193 E3 and you're identified as a school
in need of assistance corrective and
technical assistance that language was
not included as part of a CSI school and
CSI schools are actually schools that
are worse in performance than TSI
schools so our current statute has a
situation where we have two tiers we
have TSI and then below that CSI TSI
schools by state law are being
identified as in need of assistance but
CSI schools were not and so we felt like
if you're identifying the higher level
of schools as being in need of
corrective assistance you should also
identify the group of schools that's in
the lower tier because they actually
need more support than TSI schools but I
don't know if maybe that was just an
oversight in some of the original
statute I'm not sure what the intent was
to identify a higher performing group of
schools but not the lower performing
group of schools so what we did is we
just copied the language from 19 and we
added up here in lines four five and six
to the CSI schools so now both of those
groups of schools would be identified
even those not receiving Title Loan
Monies
correct so this is relative to 183 E3 so
when you go back to the 183 E3 statute
this is accountability for an adequate
education so what this is saying is you
have two groups of federally identified
schools we're saying the higher
performing group does not meet the
requirements for an adequate education
but the lower performing group does
and that just didn't make sense within
the statute so we felt like if you're if
we're identifying one group is not
meaning requirements for an adequate
education you really have to also
identify the lower performing group as
further discussion on that
okay going down to middle of the page
line 18.
there's also some dates removed I
targeted support Improvement schools
I I think this just saying it's
foreign
I think we're unclear what the question
is okay I'm just you know explain try it
can you explain why they need to add in
18 there
on line 18.
oh sure so this just matches the
schedule of determinations of when we
identify the additional targeted support
and Improvement schools to match the
comprehensive support and improving
schools
okay
yes representative cascadden uh my
question is on using the data from
2017-18
is that when that classification first
started yes okay so the very first list
of CSI and TSI schools yeah was based
off 17-18 data and then future
determinations are made based off of the
current assessment data okay thanks
yes representative Miler I'm sorry to be
very basic here but you you use the term
TSI and CSI
which is the one that's
higher and lower
so a CSI School uh is uh the C stands
for comprehensive and so that would be
the lower performing one that means that
all of your whole school is performing
in the very bottom five percent of the
state across the board a TSI school is a
school that maybe the school overall is
performing okay but you might have one
or two particular student groups that
are performing in the bottom five
percent of the state thank you
representative Tanner
and we I think we've established before
that it doesn't matter how high
everybody is there's still going to be a
bottom five percent it could be up at
the 90th percentile and they if they
were still at the and that isn't
understood by a lot of people I think
that the same thing with proficiency
which we're going to talk about next
there's a I think a lot of
um misinformation or misthought about
proficiency standards they actually
move
and uh proficient doesn't mean that
you're passing with a D or a c
so
what's your point about the bottom five
percent always being identified that is
a requirement in the federal law
um but that's a great question and
that's probably something that should be
discussed as a committee uh maybe going
forward with some additional legislation
is if your bottom five percent is
spectacular do we want to say that those
schools are not providing an adequate
education by the definition I'm not sure
that we do or don't
um so that will probably need to be
written into law and I think those were
conversations that we always thought
would be happening once we initially
determined the list so I think when we
first came up with this legislation in
2018 2019 we said all right well let's
get to the point let's do the
determinations let's do the list let's
look at what that looks like and then
now look what happens when we try to
implement it now here we are five down
ears down the road we had three years of
pandemic and quite a bit of educational
disruption
um and so we're kind of in this weird no
man's land where we thought we would be
coming back to you very shortly with an
additional plan and some conversations
or especially with maybe the legislative
oversight committee and it just hasn't
happened yet so that's why we are that's
okay
on lines 27 through 29
so this is a a particular statute that's
changed I think three times each time
the dates have changed so the
line here requires that all schools
ensure that every student is proficient
on the state test by a certain year
prior to it saying 2018-19 I believe it
said 2015-16 prior to that I think it
said 2008 2009 so there isn't
necessarily a consequence attached to
this line and there's a date that's set
um
but we don't have every student scoring
proficient on the state test in every
school and that's kind of what this line
here requires it says by this date every
student shall be proficient
so rather than continue to move the date
down the road we pulled it out just
because there isn't something that
happens afterwards so we publish the
data we know that you know many of our
students are performing at various
different levels on the state test
but there wasn't something that kind of
happened next after determining that not
yes represent
when it says by that date everybody had
to be proficient did they have to stay
proficient I mean is it just like we hit
it once and that was it uh
it's kind of a vague statute which is
sort of why we crossed that out I think
it's more than big thank you it needs to
be crossed out represent Damon
respectfully Mr chair I disagree
so we're crossing it out because we
didn't have a consequence for not
requiring students to perform at a
proficient level don't we want them to
perform at a proficient level maybe we
should if we're not achieving that
we should be addressing the fact that
we're not achieving it not taking away
the goal no I I agree I think and in
consequence is probably the bad word I
think you know a Next Step based upon a
stated year was sort of the part that
that didn't make sense is okay so we hit
2018-19
but there wasn't that next step of okay
now what and now we've gone beyond that
we're in 2023 this line is only specific
to what occurred in the year 2018-19
and so that's the part that was I
absolutely a thousand percent agree and
I think we have in both the the purpose
at the very beginning I think of 183c
that talks about the purpose of the
Statewide assessment to ensure that all
students are assessed on what they know
and can do we have I think
um as well within some of our rules at
the department and a lot of the
communication that we put out our goal
is to get every single student to be
proficient at grade level in reading and
math and science
um so it's just this particular part
that referenced that school year was a
little bit nonsensical now that we're in
2023 like consequence is probably the
bad word yeah to use but when we when we
adopted the SS stuff back years ago we
were looking at
the word growth
as well as achievement and so if
if a student is showing growth but
they're not at that proficiency level
yet for that student but they're showing
growth that's our aim that's one of our
aims yes I think that we're going to say
everybody's going to be proficient
that's you know
that's not realistic but we would like
to see growth from all students and I
think there's a really important the
language that we use when we talk about
proficiency so you know if I use fifth
grade as an example if we say that again
45 of our fifth grade student and I'm
making up a number here but if we say 45
of our fifth grade students are
proficient in Reading we're not saying
that 55 of our students can't read we're
saying that 55 of the students aren't
proficient yet at a fifth grade level
many of them are proficient at a fourth
grade level and they're making that
growth towards that fifth grade level
the vast majority of those students can
read
but in fifth grade some of the students
may be reading at a fourth grade level
uh some of those students might be
reading at a third grade level so it's
not proficient doesn't mean whether you
can do it or whether you can't do it
it's can you do it at that level that
your age has put you at in your cohort
and so that I think that's why we really
like to talk about growth as well
because those students that are in fifth
grade and reading in a fourth grade
level may have made a huge amount of
growth to get to that point and so when
we were publishing data and statistics
on our website next to the achievement
percentages we publish the growth
percentages to show what percent of
students have made growth from their
last school year to this school year and
maybe they're not on grade level yet but
they may have moved a whole grade and a
half level up in growth in the work that
they've been doing to get to the point
they're at right now
yeah represent dry
thank you Mr chairman
um when it talks about the the schools
will be performance-based indicators
assistant number two right now approved
by the Legislative oversight committee
where would we find those it says it's
in rules so where are those standards
so the Statewide performance targets
we've always used Statewide the
Statewide performance targets that were
approved in the Essa plan in 2017-18
there was a committee that had been put
together that developed the performance
targets based off of how students in New
Hampshire at each grade level had been
performing up to that point and it made
projections out I believe for the next
10 years that were relatively aggressive
projections for where we wanted students
in New Hampshire to be in each of those
subjects at each of those grade levels
and we published those Targets on our
website so each year when a School
receives the data around their Statewide
assessment that data is compared to that
Statewide performance Target and they
can see as a school have they met was
what was expected for the state for that
year did they exceed it were they below
it but much of that information is in
the state Essa plan okay follow-up yes
so does that change I mean are the
standards change or is it we have to
wait 10 years to to reevaluate it
um so the standards themselves have not
changed the standards that we're holding
students to each of those years are the
same standards
um when we get I think 10 years from
2017-18 which I think is what so 20 27
28 we'll have to reevaluate and come up
with new targets because we don't have
any Targets set right now at that point
but we do have a variety of targets for
many different areas not just the
Statewide assessment we have graduation
uh rate targets we have
um targets for percentages of students
mastering the English language learner
that are English language Learners so
there's a couple of other categories
that go beyond just the Statewide test
but yeah they all they all end I think
in 2027. and we find those where
um so those are published on the I
platform and I report as well as in the
state Essa plan okay thank you
okay this takes us down through uh the
changes which we have here it's a lot
shorter than uh now if if this is to
move forward this amendment this
amendment then would delete everything
in SB 266
and this would be 266.
so in a lot of what we did in two
success was moving things around to make
it chronologically make sense or just
kind of move different areas so that's a
lot of why you have all these Pages
um so this still this gives us the
ability to implement the law and do the
work that we need to do 266 gave us the
ability to kind of make the law book
look a little bit better
so
I don't know if we're you know up to
that in the next several weeks here to
take this as it was introduced to us
right and no I can't wait to do that I
think if you move forward with the
amendment that gives us a lot of the
work that we needed yeah and then maybe
we can talk about making some of the
well I think we're open to that uh but I
c-h-k-e right yeah and K was an entirely
new invented I know that it comes after
J right yeah well you have to move the
reporting and we know that you know
there's committees that are kind of
mixed in this there's the Holocaust
legislation that was just kind of mixed
in and we thought it deserved its own
section so we were really trying to do
an all for one I guess maybe we got a
little too ambitious would that work so
well we were kind of amazed at a bill of
that size came from the Senate as
introduced no no changes
that was that just was kind of shocking
to me uh and then when we got into it we
were waiting around and I personally was
trying to go back and forth I know gen
Ford did a side by side here for us and
it was like
it was a trial and so I don't know we're
not there yet I think we're going to
have to take it step by step
um that's fair you're you're in some
pretty heavy chapters there dealing with
education representative cascadden um I
want to commend you on this amendment
particular because I've gone through I
think three times and made notes on the
side by side and it was all over the
place and certainly some substantial
issues in there that just didn't line up
when you're talking about minimum
standards for school approval versus
criteria for education so thank you for
this I
this is succinct it's what we're talking
about and we make that one change then
Linda came up it's adapted and you know
my suggestion is that we make that one
change as a committee right here
I don't think it's necessary to come
back and talk 266 anymore I would just
as soon say we're satisfied to move
forward with this thing with that
amended change and we'll have it as a
committee Amendment
any objections that representative Damon
I have a lingering question before
agreeing to that
so on page three line 31 and then it
comes up again later I think
um
where the amendment takes out the every
three-year determination of what schools
are in which category
and I believe Dr Green you said the goal
is still every three years
yeah so how do we know that stays the
goal to re-evaluate every three years if
it's not part of the RSA
um so the so we have to set out that
schedule to the US Department of
Education I think that's sort of their
expectation some states are on a
two-year schedule but Most states in the
country are on a three-year schedule and
that's what our current approved plan
says we had a few amendments that were
in the middle of that that created these
one-year kind of changes we're back on
to that three-year cycle so it's a
standard three-year cycle that we kind
of match up with nationally
thank you
okay is there any objection to moving
forward with this amendment with that
one change
from the committee so it looks like
we're good then we'll take action on
this when we come back in November
and we should be able to move through
this and we'll get that one amendment
alrighty that closes us down there is a
meeting starts at one o'clock the
teacher shortage
committee meeting
so that that's I think that's over in
the other building no it's a 101
downstairs okay
thank you very much everybody and
enjoy the afternoon thank you very much